okay  [Applause]  I work in the cheese fields  out of my car I can't there's a camera  she's cute  [Music]  you are but you're not being very  Network following right  Nick are you choking  I'm allergic to strawberries  who are you  dead Deluxe [ __ ] Deluxe is legit crazy  you may not remember me it's just a  little pup while you're a big dog in  these streets I saw him once cut a guy's  hand off and then slap them across the  face with it I'm a fully grown man now  I've had sex before I saw him cut some  guy's ear off and they carried it around  just to yell into it and these are my  streets what yeah he even said like over  Roger it was weird like a walkie-talkie  like a walkie-talkie